[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission consacrée
au livre que vous allez pouvoir lire
durant cet été et on va commencer avec
Katarina loi Van Hoof bonjour bonjour
vous êtes la créatrice et le directrice
d'une maison d'édition qui s'appelle des
Argonautes référence grecques à la
littérature européenne puisque c'est à
cette littérature européenne que vous
vous consacrez et une littérature
européenne qu'on connaît moins bien
parce que vous écartez la partie
anglo-saxonne pour vous consacrer à
d'autres d'autres auteurs et justement
là on va parler d'une autrice italienne
d'un auteur Albanais du et du notaire
romaine que vous allez nous conseiller
un mot sur cette maison d'édition quand
même puisque alors le siège est à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye oui en fait oui
j'ai voulu mettre en avant les langues
un peu plus rares la littérature de nos
voisins
c'est la me semblait comme vous entendez
je suis allemande donc c'est un peu dans
mes dans mes je crois fortement dans la
nécessité de s'entretien à la
littérature de nos voisins et
75% des romans traduits en France le son
de l'anglais je trouve que c'est un peu
trop peut-être oui voilà
et là on peut aller sur le sur le site
des ergots c'est très très bien fait
parce que il y a il y a des cartes comme
ça avec les pays les écrivains les
livres qu'on peut lire c'est très
astucieux et très très bien fait alors
vous allez apporter trois livres on va
commencer par par une italienne et qui
s'appelle Barbara frontino et le livre
s'appelle du lapin mérité en italien je
voudrais
j'ai du mal à prononcer moi-même je
parle pas l'italien
c'est un roman c'est un roman vraiment
formidable donc c'est la seule autrice
de ma maison qui qui n'est pas encore
extrêmement connue parce que c'est son
premier roman pour adulte c'est une
journaliste et une plume elle a écrit
des livres pour pour le jeunesse pour la
jeunesse
et elle a écrit des livres pour les
autres là elle a écrit son premier
propre roman autrefois on disait ça et
c'est un roman très personnel très fort
en émotion enfin vraiment comme comme on
le lit d'un seul trait et après on a
envie de le donner
sa meilleure amie tout de suite
l'histoire un peu d'une peut-être d'une
vengeance
c'est de dire qu'elle est elle est
mariée une vedette de la télévision
il se trouve que
leur relation se sont un peu détériorées
et qu'il a il fait un AVC il fait un AVC
donc
Claudia la protagoniste elle est témoins
que son mari tombe de l'arbre qu'il est
en train de couper dans son jardin il
s'écroule il reste par terre il bouge
plus et ce qu'elle fait ça c'est la
toute première scène je gâche rien c'est
c'est elle elle reste elle reste dans sa
cuisine à boire un café un appel pas
tout de suite les secours et elle
l'accompagne non pas non plus dans à
l'hôpital donc on sait que dans un AVC
la rapidité
et on s'est demandé qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé oui qu'est-ce que c'est passé et
ce qui s'est passé et cela aussi je je
vous gâche rien c'est c'est le mari qui
l'a trompé qui a commis la trahison
ultime parce que l'autre femme attend un
enfant de lui il le dit il lui dit c'est
ça qui m'a intéressé dans ce roman c'est
donc entendu l'histoire un million de
fois
voilà on pourrait se dire après tout et
des couples qui vont mal la vengeance on
en a lu d'autre mais là ce qui est
vraiment bien c'est la franchise avec
laquelle Barbara frandino s'attaque à ce
sujet parce qu'elle c'est le mari il est
gentil il lui dit mais je t'aime
toujours il n'y a pas de raison
d'ailleurs il veut rien changer j'ai
enfin ma maîtresse en gros mais c'est
pas grave on reste ensemble c'est ça
voilà sauf que la femme elle se rend
compte Claudia elles se rencontrent que
ça met en question comme toute son
identité tout son son image qu'elle se
fait de sa vie de son couple de de son
mari qu'elle aime toujours aussi mine de
rien et elle n'arrive pas à lui
pardonner et c'est quelque chose elle va
essayer elle va essayer mais moi je
trouve écrit avec une avec une assez
sévère c'est c'est vert envers elle-même
envers lui envers lui parce que
finalement pression comme ça aucun des
personnages n'est vraiment sympathique
au fond
c'est pas quelqu'un qui dit moi je suis
bien et puis mon mari est un
c'est plus profond et plus intéressant
que ça c'est vraiment très très franc et
il se font mal et il n'y a pas il n'y a
pas de solution facile ce problème
l'enfant il va être là il va grandir et
et la preuve la preuve d'un manque dans
leur vie à eux en tant que couple et
immense et
je trouve que elle a vraiment touché là
une corde qui avec notre notre société
qui qui beaucoup dans la dans la liberté
individuelle qui qui c'est pas c'est pas
peut-être pas tellement touchant que
c'est vraiment intéressant on est on est
vraiment en plein là-dedans donc
si je crois que Barbara va venir
quelques jours en France elle arrive
demain et elle du festival le château ce
livre à la roche-couillant le premier le
1er juillet et la seconde juillet donc
le week-end prochain et elle a une
rencontre aussi rencontre dédicace à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye ce jeudi donc je
l'accueille demain voilà on peut aller
la voir et discuter avec elle et je
crois que c'est un roman qui touchera
beaucoup de beaucoup de gens des femmes
et des hommes aussi moi je pensais que
c'était un roman pour les femmes en fait
maintenant j'ai des retours de plus en
plus des hommes qui ont beaucoup aimé
donc je suis étonnée mais je je
conçois que voilà peut-être des choses
comme ça
donc Barbara frontino tu l'as bien
mérité et c'est évidemment aux idiots
des Argonautes deuxième roman
dur qui s'appelle bola
d'un écrivain qui s'appelle byteam
qui est d'original banaise oui
mais c'est un pays qui est tellement été
fermé du temps du communisme qui était
le pays le plus fermé d'Europe quoi
avec avec grand monde et pas être une
sadov tu sais encore plus spécifique
parce qu'ils viennent du Kosovo donc de
l'ex Yougoslavie donc c'est encore autre
chose que l'Albanie c'est son ethnie
c'est il est albanais mais à ses deux
ans ses parents ont décidé de de
partir en Finlande pour s'échapper à la
guerre donc
le roman a pour toile de fond la guerre
du Kos oui c'est le sujet de l'auteur
qui un grand auteur finlandais
maintenant c'est ça qui est qui
m'impressionne moi il est
arrivé enfin non à deux ans aujourd'hui
il est professeur pour l'hydratation
comparé à l'université des inki il a eu
pour ce roman voilà il a eu le prix le
plus prestigieux littéraire du pays le
finlandiaque c'est l'équivalent du
concours et à peine 30 ans donc c'est un
jeune écrivain immense mental onctueux
et comme comme son sujet c'est la guerre
de Gosselies c'est l'amour gay aussi
c'est l'amour homosexuel c'est ce n'est
pas un auteur facile mais je défie
chaque lecteur passionné pour la
littérature c'est magnifique roman et
j'ai la chance de le lire
c'est magnifique alors vous avez raison
[Musique]
auprès d'elle parce que c'est la gare il
doit fuir parce que les années sont
persécutés il n'y a aucun moyen de
rester là et Miloche son amoureux va
faire partie du camp opposé il est
médecin donc il va aller au front il va
traiter les les blessés et
qu'on arsim le retrouve des années après
après la guerre il retrouve et ce n'est
plus le même homme absolument
et la façon de laquelle donc l'auteur
décrit cette histoire de deux amoureux
échoués et il
fait il change le récit avec les avec un
la mythologie à libanaise qui celle de
bolide
qui qui est méchant qui est mauvais
et c'est vraiment magnifique donc c'est
très poétique c'est très dur c'est très
sombre mais je trouve qu'il y a aussi de
cette humanité très très forte qui qui
surgit dans les temps de guerre donc
c'est vraiment intéressant
vous êtes fier d'avoir
les plus grands auteurs du monde entier
il est vraiment quelqu'un qui va rester
et qui va évoluer ça ça m'intéresse
beaucoup alors cela ils sont ils sont
déjà dans le public on peut booster
et là on a un petit scoop si je peux
dire un livre qui va paraître au mois
d'août
d'une écrivaine roumaine d'Anna
grigorcha
qui s'appelle ceux qui ne meurent jamais
ce qui ne meurent jamais c'est donc
c'est une autrice qui roumaine mais qui
vit depuis maintenant longtemps déjà en
Suisse elle est aussi elle est aussi
Suisse
le plus gros prix de littérature suisse
les prix du livre Suisse pour l'année
dernière donc aussi pour ce livre et
c'est une autre histoire qui écrit en
allemand elle est traduit de l'allemand
par la formidable Élisabeth Landes qui
nous traductrice très très reconnue et
voilà je dois dire pour parler un peu de
vous avez travaillé chez Gallimard vous
êtes occupé beaucoup des écrivains
étrangers et donc vous connaissez tous
les meilleurs traducteurs toutes les
meilleures traductrices c'est ce qui
fait le sel aussi de la maison les
argots d'hôtes oui le travail avec les
traducteurs très important oui et là on
ne voit parce que c'est un texte
difficile profond avec beaucoup de
références historique et un langage
assez baroque et assez étrange parce que
c'est un roman de Dracula contemporain
il faut savoir il faut savoir traduire
ça oui oui et entre plusieurs cultures
donc il y a les références Abraham
stocker à Dracula et il y a des
références à la l'histoire moyenâcheuse
roumaine donc la traductrice a fait un
énorme travail en profondeur dans le
texte pour rendre ça il y a des passages
en latin de très courtes je vous rassure
mais mais c'est
un livre
non oui voilà c'est un peu ça c'est un
peu ça ça rappelle un peu ça c'est il y
a ce charme de se rappeler de tous ces
anciens
j'ai lu alors quelques critique c'est
quelqu'un disait c'est un roman
politique gothique voilà c'est ça que
dit la critique Suisse donc le noyau de
surchardsight ils disent que la loterie
ça a inventé un nouveau genre
parce que c'est vraiment génial ce
qu'elle fait c'est en face premièrement
c'est un roman qu'on dit très facilement
très sensuel plein de carnage de
vengeance et de mystère vraiment un
roman de Dracula gothique et c'est un
deuxième niveau l'autrice ça j'adore
elle nous décrit la société roumaine
d'aujourd'hui donc pose communiste
encore plus corrompu que sous le régime
parce que les anciens cadres ont repris
le pouvoir et la protagoniste la
protagoniste elle est comme l'autrice
elle fait elle est su de cette
intelligence gentille à bohème de la
Roumanie qui a bien survécu sous Charles
et qui s'est toujours moqué un peu du
mauvais goût du régime communiste donc
c'est quelque chose de très 12 ans de
très sensuelle c'est très intéressant
parce que souvent on se demande il y a
encore dans tous ces pays qui ont connu
le communisme et qui sont libérés de ce
jour mais il y a encore parfois dans les
élections une forte tendance de gens qui
votent encore pour et on se demande
pourquoi
c'est une des explications la corruption
peut-être plus forte qu'elle n'était
encore il y a la corruption et puis il y
a il y a tous le développement de
historique de ces pays-là après après la
révolution donc ils ont quand même ils
ont quand même beaucoup profité de la
nouvelle liberté mais ils ont aussi vu
surtout en Roumanie mais aussi dans
d'autres pays de l'Est ils ont vu leurs
enfants partir à l'ouest donc elle
décrit ça très bien elle décrit comment
les parents ils restent à l'ombre des
ruines que les enfants ont construit
dans le jardin quand ils ont encore
pensé qu'ils allaient revenir un jour
donc ils ont construit des maisons à
côté de l'ancien maison des parents un
étage deux étages trois étages et ils
sont restés à l'ouest sont plus jamais
revenus et les parents restent là à côté
de cette ruine
pas terminée et sans les enfants et
c'est quand même quelque chose qui oui
ces pays-là sont encore fortement
marqués par leur histoire et par ses
développements
précédents aussi à bord voilà l'histoire
par le romanesque c'est toujours
passionnant
ce que j'aime beaucoup mais c'est d'une
manière sensuelle et c'est hautement
divertissant parce que la protagoniste
rencontre le compte en personne c'est
pas il est vraiment là vraiment
écoutez merci pour ce pour ces conseils
je rappelle le titre donna grigorcia
ceux qui ne meurt jamais alors ça
attendez le mois d'août pour le procurer
un mot ça fait combien de temps
maintenant les Argonautes ça fait depuis
le mois de janvier des livres oui six
mois et oui c'est très sympathique je
suis extrêmement heureuse je rencontre
mes auteurs je travaille sur les
manuscrits j'adore ça et c'est un
travail très riche avec les traducteurs
c'est la langue et c'est vraiment très
très sympathique après voilà
l'accueil du public est très positif
après ce qui ce qui est difficile en ce
moment c'est le marché du livre donc le
papier est toujours très cher les
surcoûts de production sont importants
et le public ne seront plus autant
libérer que on avait l'habitude donc on
lit un petit peu moins en ce moment je
pense qu'on est occupé avec autre chose
et il faudrait que ça revient mais moi
je suis très optimiste il y a tellement
de tes histoires à
raconter et à savourer que
ça devrait
être d'histoires dans lequel on peut se
projeter
oui elle est un peu ailleurs ça fait du
bien
merci infiniment Katarina of
donc bon on reviendra peut-être à la
rentrée
pour pour ce travail absolument fabuleux
que vous faites merci beaucoup bonne
journée
[Musique]